points ce soir à 21h heure locale des
dizaines de millions d'américains auront
les yeux rivés sur cleveland où a lieu
le premier débat entre le président
donald trump et son rival joe biden
l'ancien vice-président de barack obama
est aujourd'hui l'espoir de tous ceux
qui espèrent la défaite du milliardaire
le démocrate de 77 ans qui au nom des
précautions sanitaires mène une campagne
plus discrète que celle tambours
battants de l'ex-homme d'affaires sera
comme rarement sous les projecteurs
connu pour ses maladresses verbales joe
biden a admis que la confrontation
télévisée entre les deux hommes serait
difficile j'espère que je ne me
laisserai pas amorcé dans une bagarre
avec ce type car c'est le seul endroit
où il est à l'aise donald trump de son
côté ne cesse de railler l'absence de
dynamisme de son rival qu'il surnomme
joe lando remis comme il ya cinq ans le
président adepte des débats animés à
assurer ses arrières en début de semaine
celui qui est le favori c'est ce lipide
jo je suis celui qui est sans expérience
je fais cela seulement depuis quelques
années cela fait plus de quarante sept
ans qu'elle est dans l'arène alors que
le début de son mandat a affiché de bons
chiffres notamment ce qui concerne le
chômage
une grande partie de l'électorat
pourrait reprocher aux milliardaires la
mauvaise gestion de l'épidémie qui a
fait plus de deux cent mille morts dans
le pays
les questions raciales et la violence
figureront aussi parmi les six sujets du
débat tout comme la succession de ruth
bader ginsburg à la cour suprême
je pense que les partisans du président
trump vont dire vous voyez il est fort
il a raison le vice-président by dane
est faible il cache quelque chose et je
pense que les partisans du vice
président biden vont regarder le débat
et dire vous voyez je le savais bail
d'un effort il est calme il unit trump a
perdu pied y la vente des choses il est
clairement corrompus je pense que les
deux parties vont s'auto déclaré
vainqueur après ce premier duel de 90
minutes deux autres débats sont encore
prévues pour départager les deux
candidats avant la présidentielle du 3
novembre